why don't we go next to uh
jason from oahu is that in hawaii
i do can you hear me okay i can i think
the tubes must be narrow coming in from
hawaii because you sound a little bit uh
strange but i i'm
curious how things are going there yeah
things are great out here
um i just wanted to comment on your
recent segment on the right-wing
propaganda and the architecture of it
i thought it was brilliant thank you
good question though what
so in regards to the specific topic that
carlson was talking about
what do you think like the implications
or do you think it's that far fetched to
think that
there might be some kind of subversion
going on with the fbi
we know that there were proud boys and
what was the oath keepers that were
there
what would be what would necessarily be
the the
bad thing that he was saying um or what
he was implying with that segment
there's no evidence for it whatsoever so
as i said before you know some right
wingers now they love to say
by the way are you brewing tea what what
is that noise
i'm actually i'm on my way to work oh
okay um so
i'll meet my mic while you speak sure
yeah so so here's here's the deal
um a lot of right wingers now love to
say you stupid liberals
now all of you love the cia you love the
fbi
you all think american intelligence
agencies can do no wrong
because of uh their concern around trump
and russia and all of this different
stuff that's not the case whatsoever
it's sort of like with the lab leak
coveted stuff uh i'm not against
investigating anything the problem is
tucker did a segment
with no evidence where he went in a
three-minute period
from these folks could be fbi agents
to these were fbi agents to the fbi
organized the trump riots all without
evidence so
if anybody organized the riots i want to
know about it but we can't just shift
the narrative to this is what happened
without any actual evidence and so far
there's been no evidence presented
whatsoever
we were aware of like an oath keeper
dude
who was functioning as an fbi informant
that's a very different thing than the
fbi planned orchestrated and perpetrated
the the trump riot so
what the what tucker did wrong is that
he presented no evidence
there's no evidence for what he's saying
right no yeah i think uh and again that
was a brilliant way of pointing that out
and like
showing your audience including myself
tools to recognize that
i guess um i don't know it just seems uh
to me that it would have been easy to
kind of identify these things if the
republicans hadn't blocked
the uh january 6th commission so that's
another point that's another point which
is all of a sudden now they're demanding
investigations
they blocked the investigation and
you're you're completely right about
that
hey thanks for taking my call my
pleasure my pleasure uh would love to
get to hawaii someday
would love to get there one of our
sponsors today is strategic voters a new
podcast that features
election experts political campaign
strategists and everyday americans
who sit down and discuss the biggest
issues in the u.s political landscape
on the activism side strategic voters as
an organization
aims to encourage people to vote with
the benefit of the country
as a whole in mind instead of just
voting one party
down the ballot if you want to hear some
really different
and interesting opinions and approaches
to voting and viewing policies
give the strategic voters podcast a
listen
the latest two episodes feature rachel
cobb and lana atkinson as guests i've
been listening to it myself
i've been really enjoying it it's very
grassroots and independent which i love
find the strategic voters podcast on all
major podcast platforms and make sure to
follow them
on twitter at strategic voters